so welcome everyone and thank you for
coming to our session implementing event
solution strategy on azure
and elena a little bit about what we are
going to talk about today
yeah
i mean obviously about sourcing
um yeah so this session the idea for the
session came to to us when i was working
in a product company and i was starting
working with
cosmos db asia cosmos db and
i was sharing with ed many times like
how how cool how many features they are
and let's propose to let's create a
session around it and in our opinion
cosmos db we had was a really good fit
for event sourcing strategies so that's
why we pulled a session around it and we
want to share today how to actually
implement it all together on asia
uh yeah and once again my name is selena
borzanko i'm working second day in a
company called experience
um
you can find me on twitter feel free to
reach out leave comment feedback i'm
always happy for for any any kind of
communication so
so thank you and so i'm al trodburg i
come from netherlands i work at company
commotion 10. we focus on everything
microsoft but myself i mostly focus on
azure and integration i'm also as an
fp so i love doing these kind of talks i
do love speaking blogging writing
basically anything i can do with the
community i try to do so thank you for
having me here today and same for me if
you have any questions any remarks
please let me know i'm always available
on my social media so definitely reach
out
there and with that let's go to quick
introduction and event sourcing so today
we are going to focus mostly on how can
we implement event sourcing on azure not
so much on event sourcing itself
but i do want to give a quick
introduction just to make sure that
everyone's on the same page like okay if
we talk about event sourcing what are we
actually talking about
so i grabbed this nice picture from the
microsoft docs page
and this kind of explains okay so what
is event sourcing
and
on just one second let me just make sure
that i'm plugged in before my
battery dies there we go
um so event sourcing as name suggests is
all about events
and so what you can see
oh not that one
this one
so what you can see here basically from
your presentation layer so from your
application you're going to create
events
and so events can be something like okay
i created the cart
i added an item i added another item and
these are all events with some
information about how do you want to
change the state of your entity so in
this case you have an
entity that is a shopping basket and we
are chasing changing the state of the
entity by creating it adding articles to
it
removing articles adding shipping
information and we all store this in
this event stored over here which we
will see later on with his implant with
us on cosmos db
but before we go to that let's also
focus a little bit on this because we
also will be focusing on this part
so what we are going to show you today
as well is how can you create material
issue on top of those events and
materials use basically okay you want to
display the information in some way
which we'll talk about more later
you can also have systems applications
that just read those events directly so
without materials view in this case
they've just replayed those events and
by replaying those events by you can
eventually get the final state of that
empty so in this case we would have a
shopping cart with one item in there
and some shipping info
and of course you can also replay those
events in any way that you want so
anyone can just basically come to our
event store say hey i want to get
current state of this
particular order please give to me they
get all the events they played back and
that way they can get us
so like i said not a deep dive on event
sourcing but definitely like a quick
introduction so okay what's event
sourcing so it's all about events and
those events you can store you don't
store the entity itself you store those
events and by storing those events and
playing them back you can get the
current state of that empty
so why should we use event sourcing and
for that first let's have a look at crot
because i think everyone here at some
point built a cut application
you create some data you create an
entity you store it into database uh you
update it you might delete some parts of
it but basically working with this
singular entity in the database
now this is fine and then as long as
your application
is not that large you can also do a lot
with large applications by the way i'm
not saying this is not possible but it
gets harder and why does get harder when
we start doing like millions of
producers and stuff like that
because you start locking your data
because when you're working with the
database if an entity is being changed
you don't want another producer to work
on the same entity because they might be
overriding the same fields
or they might be reading data that's out
of
this out of sync so you have to lock the
data make sure no one can actually
adjust the data except for that one
producer
and like i said this is fine if you're
working with like thousands of
producers but once you get into like
millions of producers this does become a
hassle
also concurrency is quite difficult when
you work with like those kind of high
traffic high throughput applications
because um one producer is inserting
something another producer is reading
the data
and they might get with an obsolete
state because someone else already
updated it and so this concurrency is
quite hard when you do this with the
normal crud
so the main problem is that crud is not
easily scalable once again i'm not
saying it's not scalable of course you
can do this but it takes a lot of effort
where event sourcing will as we see in
moments solve a lot of these issues for
us
finally
something that always annoyed me because
i want to see what happened to my entity
and with crouch you don't have an out of
the box history you can of course build
your own locking database and
just keep track of every change that you
made but it's something that you have to
build yourself on top of your
application in your database in a
separate table
so the event sourcing pattern basically
helps on these kind of scenarios
because you only do inserts you don't do
updates so you don't have those locking
issues you don't have those concurrency
issues everyone just sends an event
saying hey i want to change this on my
particular entity
and this is really nice when you have
those right heavy workloads like i said
we're talking about millions of
producers uh where this is like the
ultimate pattern of course you can also
use on the lower air throughput but this
is actually where it was made for like
this high throughput
with many producers on there
and this is because inserts are just
much more efficient you can just do an
insert and as long as your database or
datastore can handle those inserts
you'll be fine you don't think about
updating you don't have to think about
locking you don't think about the
currency as long as i can do inserts i
can implement event sourcing and we'll
see in a moment why cosmodb is such a
great for this
and of course because you just insert
those events you already have your other
lock because your events are your other
lock
because when you play those back those
events you can immediately see like what
happened to this order who changed
something who updated the current state
and that's all just out of the box with
event sourcing so this is why i like
event sourcing a lot for these kind of
scenarios
you mentioned for the crude uh we that
it's not easily scalable yes so how is
it scaled to
yeah so event sourcing is much easier
scalable because like i said as long as
you can handle those inserts and of
course you have to get a data store that
actually can handle those millions of
inserts at the same time
um but as long as you can handle this
then you will be okay so
because you don't have to think about
that locking issue and stuff like that
anymore you just have to handle inserts
um and there's a moment we're going to
talk about like how cosmos db does this
and why this is so amazing for this
but i do think this is also the power of
the cloud in general because the cloud
actually allows us to just scale up and
definitely basically
actually do these kind of things with
our
with our applications
so let's have a look on event sourcing
on azure and of course we are talking
about azure today here but the same
applies basically to any other cloud
provider awsa similar services i'm sure
google cloud has similar services
so if you're not working with azure
yourself just know like you can probably
map this on your own services we are
going to show this on azure and of
course azure is the best cloud so we
should all be using this
so event sourcing and azure so first of
all cosmos db and elena is going to talk
a bit about this yes so we're going to
use azure cosmos db for those who never
worked with this never met it it's a
globally distributed massively scalable
document based database
um they have different apis so as you
can see there is a table api cassandra
sql mongodb or gremlin by default if you
would start working with cosmos db
they're going to be sql but
why why it's great for us
as we already saw as we already said
that
we want to have
an option to in just insert our events
without
any updates and asia cosmos db is a
schema-less document store so we will be
able just to insert documents
uh without basically carrying what about
schema but about version of the document
and so on so on so and it's also
globally distributed so multi-regions
they have a lot of um basically
um
regions where you can have the data very
close to the user so it's also optimized
the performance of storing of writing
operation read operations
and of course like there's guarantee for
very low latency
yes
so as you can hear it like cosmos b is
really that kind of data store that you
want for an event sourcing pattern
because it can just handle high loads
it doesn't matter where those events
come from like you can have in the
multiple regions where actually multiple
users can write to the regions
and this is really nice for that kind of
pattern
but of course you are not going to
expose our data store directly to the
internet so our producers will actually
talk to something else first and they're
going to send their events into event
hubs and event hubs is a stream based
message store and so think like kafka
because i think most people here will
have seen kafka at some point or event
ups itself but think like i can just
push in events and i can then have a
stream of events that i can read from
and think of this a bit like a tape deck
so i can go forward in the day deck i
can go backwards in my
deck and same for my stream so i can
just go forward in my stream backwards
in my stream i can say i want to start
playing from this point that can be the
beginning it can be somewhere halfway it
can be specific entry specific time so i
can basically just go over the stream
and this is actually done by the client
so the client is in control of putting
the cursor of okay where do i want to
start playing back those events
and this of course is very nice if you
say okay so we had some issues i want to
get the events from the last day again i
can just put that cursor back and it
just will start playing again or if i
introduce a new client they will just
get the complete stream they can start
from beginning and just play back all
those events
and once again this is also very
optimized for high throughput
event apps can also handle millions of
events per second so it's really once
again a great partner in our event
sourcing pattern
yeah and of course azure functions um
thanks for the building triggers for
azure functions for the event hub for
cosmos db it will be super easy to
implement
uh basically functionality how we want
to write our data in cosmos db how we
want to also react on those changes and
also because it's serverless uh
very very nice that we don't need to pay
basically for
uh for the
for having azure functions we pay only
when we use them
and uh of course it also will help us to
concentrate only on our business logic
uh combining triggers and bindings we
can avoid like a huge amount of code we
can just add how we want to actually
aggregate our data how we want to
aggregate our events and like save it
back to cosmos db or any other data
store
exactly
so with these three different services
we are going to implement this this
event sourcing pattern on azure
and
with that actually let's have a look how
this looks like
so what i'm going to do in this demo i
have a kafka enabled i have a kafka
application and the nice thing about
event hubs it actually has a kafka
compatible endpoint so if you are
working with kafir kafka at the moment
you can just change your connection
string to event tops and we'll actually
just send those events into event hubs
or on the other side to retrieve them
from them without changing any code
so this is very nice that i can just
have kafka application and go to event
hops to have completely managed platform
i don't have to host my own kafka
service anymore or anything like that
it's all completely managed for me it's
a pure pass service so i only think
about my logic and no longer about
infrastructure or anything like that
so that kafka application is going to
push it into event hubs it will be
pushed into that stream and once events
are starting to come in we are going to
trigger a function on this so we have an
event.binding that sees hey there's some
events coming in i need to start reading
the stream
and we'll get those events and of course
we can apply some logic in here in this
case we just pass them through direct
directly to cosmos db but for example if
i would want some transformations or
maybe some validations this would be the
point where i would insert that custom
logic that custom business process
in this case we just push them through
into cosmos db and store them there as
our event store
so let's have a look at what this looks
like
so first of all i have my kafka producer
over here um i'm not going to dive too
deeply into the code
this is not a session about the
programming or anything like that i will
show you some parts of this just like to
let you know how to do this if you
actually want to have a better look at
the code and want to start playing
around with this yourself uh we have
everything on github we'll share the
link in the end so you can have a look
at this yourself and actually spin up
all the services all the infrastructures
code is there all the codes for the
application is there so you can actually
spin this up yourself
um and this is so much so this is my
producer so this is going to create some
events and send them out to my
event hubs and what we are simulating
here is that warehouse we were talking
about earlier
of course in real life this would be
many different applications that always
be sending their events i just have one
single application that is going to
simulate all those different
systems
but what you will see here on this line
is that we are just using the
confluent.kafka library so this is just
normal kafka um
that you might already be have built
yourself as well
um nothing special just a kafka
application
and the only thing i had to do to make
this work with event hubs is this
connection string actually put in the
connection string of my event ups
everything else is similar like you can
run this against kafka it will work
exactly the same as it does against
event tops no code changes needed
so what i'm going to do i'm going to
create a some produce a producer and i'm
going to create 1000 different tasks and
this will create 1000 different orders
and go to different stages of that order
so when i create processed order i'm
going to create some random orders with
some random data in there
i'm going to add some
customer info and so this part over here
will be my first event
so this will just be a json document
that is sent as an event
now as you can see i have a couple
different stages that we go through so
order is requested so someone actually
was
actually on the website said okay i want
this order it's requested
and it will then go to another system uh
add some more articles it goes another
system
accepts it like okay we are going to
process this order so this is another
event that we are creating here
um as you will see there's f times the
submit and weight and this just
simulates like okay we are submitting it
and there will be some time in between
those different processes and that's a
random time in between there
so we can update our articles in some
cases
we can cancel our order in some cases
most of them will still end up in the
picking phase where it's actually in the
where i was being picked
it goes out for delivery and finally
order gets delivered so these are
different stages that go through and as
you can see these are just different
events and these can come from different
applications different systems where
each system just says hey i'm doing
something to this order
so let's start this one so it's going to
run it's going to create our orders and
send them out to our event hops and that
will start the function that will see
hey something is in this event hub i
need to start processing this stream
so it's now creating some data so there
we go orders are being sent
so while this is running let's go to the
function that's going to trigger from
this
and this is my event processor function
i already deployed this in azure so this
is actually processing the data that's
coming in and while that is doing that i
will run you to the bit code here as
well
and elena already told us that functions
have the concept of bindings and
triggers
and so the nice thing about binding and
triggers is that i don't need to know
for example in this case how does event
ups work i don't need to know about
check marking i don't need to know about
how does the stream work i don't need to
know about the pointer that's all
handled for me the only thing i do is
add this one line over here
so i just say i want event up trigger
this is my event type that you have to
listen on
this is my connection string and i want
back an event data
array
and that's all i need to know so i get
an array with events and i can just
start processing them without having to
know all about how do i connect to event
hubs how do i do all this kind of logic
around this this all abstracted away
from me that's very nice because it
means that i can to get started very
quickly i don't have much logic that i
need to maintain i can just use this and
get those events in
i'm also going to write some cosmos db
and i'm actually going to use the sdk
and i'm going to do that exactly because
what i just said those trigger and
bindings abstract a lot of things away
which is amazing if you only need the
default logic but if you want to do
something more on this like you want in
this case i'm going to add some
parameters on my custom db client
this you cannot do with those bindings
so if you want a bit more control you
can of course still use the sdk as i
will be doing but i did want to show you
how this look like if i would actually
use that binding
so in that case i would have this cosmos
db binding i would say okay this my
collection my database my collection
my connection string
and then i would have an output document
and so this is just a document i can
write to and then put it as soon as
write to it it will push it out to my
customer to be
now like i said i'm using something else
i'm using the client over here the
cosmic cosmos client
and that's because i want to have these
serialized options which i cannot do on
my binding
now if you are like okay i need this in
many different projects
very many different functions you can
actually write your own custom binding
and then of course on your custom
binding you can actually implement this
and then you once again use a binding
in this case i just want to show you
that you also have still this all this
control that you can actually just use
the sdk for all the different services
and use that to write to this
so i'm going to create my database if it
doesn't exist i'm going to create my
containers
and then i'm going to look through those
events that are coming in so this or
just an array of events that i'm going
to run through and going to store into
cosmos db
um like i said i'm not doing much
special here i'm just going to get that
event and store it as the json document
that comes in but of course i can do a
lot of custom logic here like
validations mappings transformations
whatever you want
in this case i just get my message body
i convert it to an order object
i make sure that i remove all the null
values and stuff like that because i'm
using the same order object for all my
different events
um so i want to skip like remove all the
null values and empty fields and stuff
like that of course you can also use
different events like elena said it's a
schemeless data store so i can also have
different kinds of events cosmodb
doesn't really care about this as long
as there's some data in there it will
work
and then i'm going to just push this
into my cosmos db i'm using upsert but
of course like i said we don't do
updates we just use inserts in in this
case
so i'm just inserting that event into
our cosmos db and it will then be there
to handle
now if i go over over here so i have my
azure environment here
here we see that i have an event hop uh
over here with one event up in this so
my orders you already see there's some
throughputs coming through here
and this is just the orders event hub
that i'm pushing these messages into
so nothing too special see here it's
just a stream of data that i'm pushing
into and then we can stop browsing this
i have my function app over here which i
just showed you that's running the
function uh that i showed which will
push data to customer to be
so the more interesting one is actually
this one
our cosmic db itself
because this is where those events are
being stored and this is where we can
start querying them start processing
them
and actually start working with them
so if i go over here in my items i will
see that i have a lot of different items
over here already
so i i'm using about 1000 different
orders with each of them about five
different events so you can imagine that
this will be long list so i'm not going
to
go to all of them but just show you how
this looks like
it's just a json document that i got for
my that was produced in my kafka
producer sent to my event hubs and then
stored into cosmos db
i can see there's some information about
the customer in here some articles
and what i want to show you so i already
paired one order beforehand because i
can now just say i want filter on this
specific
order number
and now i see for this specific order
number i have some different events so
this is my event sourcing pattern that
you see here because i have an event
that was created or requested
i have another event that looks
completely different that it was
accepted so this came from another
system
i have another event that is picking so
this came from our picking systems
an event that's out for delivery
and finally an event that was delivered
and so now my clients can actually just
play back those five events and they
will see okay so i have an order with
this order number for this customer this
were the articles it was accepted at
this moment it was picking at this
moment it went out for delivery at this
moment it was delivered at this moment
and so by playing back those five events
they cannot have complete state of this
specific order
so that's the event sourcing pattern
implemented on top of our azure services
and
next up we are actually going to see
so we now have those events in our data
store and now we're going to see how we
can create those materialized views
and elena is going to tell all about
that
yes so basically my partners will be
about reading all those events so we
already brought them a massive amount of
data in in cosmos db now we have to
extract somehow this data because we're
not going to to query uh
all these events and aggregate it in
real time uh because this would not be
just efficient uh in a with a relational
database for example that might work we
will have just query we will run it
anytime we want and then we will have
aggregated view or whatever for cosmos
db that's not that's not the case
because uh i mean it will just end up in
a in uh
that our cosmos db will be super
expensive for a couple of reasons first
of all because it's not
uh because of the partitioning in cosmos
db
um if we will just write the query and
we'll try to extract all this data in in
the ring
we will just end up querying having a
cross-partition queries and this is very
expensive so uh to avoid that kind of
operations we
will be creating we will create
pre-populated views so we will save
those queries result of those queries we
will save them in the cosmos db and this
will basically uh
be for optimization of read operations
and
any time when there is update will
happen update in our case we'll be
adding a new document but for cosmos db
it any change if there if you update the
document if you insert a new document
uh we have an option to react on those
changes and to react on those changes we
have a cosmos db change feed
basically
the complete lock of all the changes
which are happening in our container um
in all the containers for every
container there is a separate change
feed
and
we can interact with the change fit
in three different ways so as you can
see when application writes some data in
cosmos db a change feed stores all this
all this information and we can pull
this data uh from the change feed and
create different projections so
when we are pulling the data from a
change feed uh it's this is the most
complicated way to interact with this
because we have to take care of uh which
partition we're going to um to use we
have to handle all the exceptions we
have to deploy it we have to manage and
scale and everything is basically on us
the use case which would be great if we
for example decided that we want to
transfer all our data in a different
data store and then we can use this pool
model
we pull all the data all the events from
the very beginning transfer them in a
different data store and we are done
the second option how to interact with
change feed feeders could be implemented
and change fit processor library
using this library we can it's basically
sdk
on top of a change feed where the pool
operation is done for us already so we
we provide the container name and then
the database with the connection string
that we want to listen
and anytime there is a change happening
or those events going to be pushed to us
then we can process in any way we want
we still have to deploy we still have to
take care of a couple of things but this
is much easier way to interact with the
change feed
and the last one
that we will use it's the azure
functions with the trigger so we will
use cosmos db trigger and cosmos db
bindings uh when there is a change gonna
happen uh something will be added or
updated in cosmos db those events will
be pushed to us but this is much easier
than the previous two
ways because we just have to publish it
on asia and asia going to take care of
of everything for us
so
basically that's the idea we're going to
consume those events and aggregate them
and create and pre and pre-save those
materials to use basically projections
so before you go ahead like you're
saying like we are going to recreate
them and we are going to as you are
saying we are going to duplicate our
data for different types views now um
when i was in school and it was very
long ago but i think many people here
will remember this like when i was in
school i was always taught like never
duplicate data you normalize data
um so here you are saying now and we are
going to actually
duplicate our data so what changed and
why do we do this this way instead of
normalizing basically as i already said
it's the the way how asian cosmos db
works because they use partitioning
um they um
basically
okay so
why we why we have to duplicate our data
because
we provide the partition key when we
store our data and for the cosmos db it
means that they have different physical
servers it calls
physical partitions where they store our
data
and they guarantee for us the data which
is aggregated in the same logical group
which is logical partition will be
always stored in the same physical
server however it doesn't mean that the
whole database which that we have gonna
be stored in the same place so
when we
if you have like really massive amount
of data our data might be distributed
between the different different physical
servers servers
and um in this way if you will start
querying this data we will just end up
like hitting different logical
partitions and different physical
partitions and this will end up in a
really significant cost so for us it
will be much better way to aggregate
this data and duplicate it because the
cost force for storing data is like 50
cents or something per gigabyte
um
and cost for request units is much more
much more expensive so
uh
dublicating this data
as much as we want like the same amount
of data can be represented in different
projections can be pre-saved for
different clients and this will be my
this will be much cheaper than if you
will try to calculate it in real time
thank you
and
now we will go to a demo part so we um
after we wrote all the data in cosmos db
we will have also asia as a function
with
cosmos db trigger we will react on those
changes and we will create two different
materialized views
two different projections and we will
save them back in cosmos db and of
course they will be available for
our clients
and first of all i will go to them
oops
yep
yeah so
here we can see
that we're going to have a warehouse
view trigger and customer view trigger
so basically it's two different
age functions
in
this is example of having one function
up and two different uh azure functions
for our case uh normally like if if we
would implement it in real time we would
even have two different functions up for
two different uh functions because then
in this way it's easy easier to scale
and they will be absolutely
independently just for us for demo
purpose we decided to keep it in one
function up so we do need to
deploy additionally the second one
and in this case what we have
as i mentioned already we have to
specify the container and the database
and also the connection string to our
cosmos db
and we using the list collection name
it's a order list container is just to
handle the state between azure functions
of change feed
and
this prefix
because i'm using two different
functions for creating my projections
but i don't want to create two different
list containers i want to share those
resources i can provide this prefix and
this means that the same container will
be used
but they will share basically they will
share resources and they will use like
this warehouse trigger will use the
resources for the warehouse group and
the customer view trigger will use
resources for the customer group but the
same container basically
and
in this case we have a cosmos db trigger
and we also using cosmos db binding
so
this binding is
will provide me a functionality of
cosmos client so i'm not going to
connect to a specific collection to pull
data or write data when my azure
function will finish execution i want to
get the whole cosmos client because i
want to read some data i want to
validate it i want to create projection
projection for my
for my events and i want to save it back
in cosmos so this is a bit more complex
operation but normally if you would want
to just return some data
from azure function you can use for
example
input binding on the start of the azure
function
pull the data from the container and
then return it back to the client if you
want
so here i'm
creating the warehouse service it's just
to have some my business logic for
handling the events
and i'm just
i will just iterate uh through the
documents here on this lines i will
deserialize my object my document back
to the object order and i will call on
on my service
handle warehouse view which is basically
will just aggregate all the events and
if i already have projection it will
just update it if i don't have the
projection it will just create a new one
the same the same situation is with a
customer view trigger absolutely the
same logic uh i'm just iterating through
the documents
again deserializing and and handling the
information
so if i would show how we can how we
actually handling this
here is this customer service for
example i'm using for customer
projection
handle customer view as i already said
just i'm trying to get the document and
see if i already have a projection if i
don't have i'm creating a new one if i
have i'm just updating
the
the interesting thing is is how we
actually inter interacting with the
cosmos db for example
uh in in this case uh we have a
repository which is basically our data
layer how we in in what way we
interacting with cosmos
db and our data in the containers
and i'm providing here id when i want to
read the document i'm providing here id
which will be id of the document and
actually partition key
so i know that they're going to be
unique so i'm using the same value for
both properties and in this case it will
be point read operation
so
it will cost me one request unit if my
document will be
less than one kilobyte in any size
if i want to um if for example my my
document does not exist i will receive a
cosmos exception that's that's how it
works you you cannot
specify different behavior and for
example return now you have to handle it
on your own
provide the custom logic
for creation and update of document um
it's very similar the only difference is
here i'm replacing my my projection and
here i'm creating a new one
we can also say that enable content
response and write equal to false it
means that it's a bit of optimization it
means that i would not receive newly
created or updated object
and in this case i'm also providing
partition key explicitly
that's also for for kind of a micro
optimization
if you would not do this it's also fine
because sdk will extract it under the
hood on its own
and
let's go to a portal
and you already saw that we have here
two additional containers i hope it's
yeah
so
while eldert was running his part of the
demo my asia functions were already
published on
asia so they were already reacting on
the changes in the order container so
here we have hub monitoring and customer
overviews
and if you'll have a look on the items
yep we have some information
as i mentioned already for id of the
document and the partition key uh
pro
partition key property i'm using the
same value for the
warehouse overview i'm using warehouse
id and just today's date it means that i
will be able to easily get the document
for today and see how many orders were
created in my warehouse for today
and this is going to be a situation for
every warehouse for every day of
how our business is up and running
basically as you can see here uh i don't
really have much information i just have
a count how many orders and order
numbers
that might be helpful for
finding for example in which warehouse
our order was placed or how many orders
in general were placed in this warehouse
for maybe some dashboards if someone
ever was in the warehouses uh there is
always some displays how many orders are
incoming how many
um yeah many orders were fulfilled and
this is basically will allow us to have
a point read so this operation will be
super cheap
and any time
it will be available we don't need to
calculate anything in
real time the same for the customer
again we are using customer id and id so
customer id properties of our partition
key
pass and id of the document is the same
values
and it's again will give us a point read
operation super cheap in this case uh
document is a bit bigger but still i
guess it's not
more than one kilobyte but it might be a
good idea to divide this document for
example for some other needs but in my
case i want to be able to show for my
customer somewhere on the web page or
maybe on the phone the overview of the
orders and the articles he he or she
ordered so we have all the orders for
the specific customer
16 the count of this orders and
a bit of information so if you have any
articles what was the status what what
is the order number basically the only
information we need and
it's all available in one document
and easily accessible
so
let's go back to the presentation as we
already saw it's super easy
yep
as you already saw it's super easy to
uh basically react on the changes in
cosmos db react on on this events
aggregate them and write them back in
cosmos db so in our case we just created
easily two projections um without
massive amount of code we just used
azure functions with those all those
triggers and bindings a bit of business
logic and we are ready to go we are
ready to expose our data for the clients
so we
going to
to the end of our session and
do a bit of
summarizing and finalizing a couple of
key takeaways
so we already saw the cosmos db could be
a great
central append only persistent data
store we can easily insert all the in
all the documents all the events which
are happening with our data and
afterwards we can operate and consume
those events in in the way as we want
yeah so when you are running into these
like scenarios where you need like white
heavy workloads do have a look at this
pattern because like i said this pattern
is really optimized for that it's not
only usable for that but it's definitely
optimized with those kind of patterns
where those kind scenarios where you
have millions of producers there's a lot
of events coming in and that you just
want to be able to replay
those events to actually get to your
store to your object
as we have seen like on azure it's
actually quite easy to implement this
it's all pass servers that we used so
everything is managed for you
you don't have to think about
infrastructure anything like that
it's all very easily usable and
especially especially when you start
using those bindings for example in
functions
you really can just focus on your
business logic
instead of having to focus on all the
things around it
and what we see in practice like i've
been working with many different clients
that use these services elena has been
working with different projects on this
it just makes things much faster much
easier
and so actually are you just creating
value for the business instead of
spending money
them money for the business
you for
uh so
it's easy to prepare much less views for
various consumers
uh so couple of benefits from this like
for event sourcing in general first of
all we have the same
set of data we have single source of
truths we have all the events and we
generate all our projections based on
the same amount of data this also could
be great for the smog testing for
example if you want to replay our events
again from the specific point of time or
maybe from very beginning we can easily
do this with the change fit we can just
connect to change feed replay it and see
what happened and in what period of time
the problem happened
so and also when we adding for example
new consumers the new clients uh it's
easy for us to
prepare the prepare these projections
prepare those materials use again we can
just connect to change feed pull the
data and be ready to go with the new
clients yes
and so finally
have a look at the ecosystem if you want
to like i said
focus more on value and less on spending
money
we showed you three serves today
but of course there's at the moment like
i think 250 plus ish shirts out there
and i always see like a
box of lego like there's many different
pieces and you can put them all together
and start building your own solutions by
using those services that make sense for
your scenarios
so um the service needs to show you
there are definitely very amazing
services but there's many more other
very nice services out there that you
could use for this so once you start
looking in your own scenarios definitely
have a look at all those different
services start mapping them
microsoft already has some help for you
on this like there's some websites and
um overviews like okay if you want to
iot these are the servers that you need
to look into stream processing there's
these services but have a look at those
services have a look at your scenario
and start mapping those services on your
scenario
so that you actually create the best uh
the best solution for what you are
trying to accomplish
yeah and also that
there is a different services like for
for us for me when i was working in the
product company was very important to
have a real-time aggregation basically
when you have warehouse system you want
to be able to be able at any point of
time to say do we still have this
article do we do we have enough products
and can we really fulfill our orders and
for example
with cosmosdb it's possible to have that
kind of aggregations but it would be a
bit expensive because we will need to
all the time in real time calculate it
and what what is great with about asia
ecosystem that they have apache spark
for example uh can connect in um
uh under the hood to the uh azure cosmos
db replicas and can have those
calculations in real time for us and
it's like that's basically the purpose
of of apache spark to do this so uh have
a look always around the features maybe
some things are already implemented and
ready ready for us to use
and um yeah also it's uh they have a
free tire it's a cosmos db is available
for testing so
before it was the case like it's too
expensive to try it's too expensive to
to work with this but now it's not the
case so you can pay as you use and you
can also uh first months it's uh free
yeah actually the three tiers is
actually free for as long as you want uh
up to five gigabytes and i think like
400 requests units so they actually
changed it also like they induce a new
tiers so you have indeed the free tier
which is like you can use as long as you
want if you have small data sets surface
if you want to pay as you go or
just normal so to say where you actually
pay for your consumption
and you pay for x amount of your request
units yeah
so
and this
thanks a lot for the attention uh here's
our details linkedin or twitter feel
free to
um to contact us if you have any
questions or comments
and thanks aldad for for being an
amazing co-speaker it was really a
pleasure to be here today and enjoy the
rest of the conference yes so thank you
everyone uh thank you for being here of
course
thank you for being at the conference
it's really good to actually be here
back in oslo again i was here in 2019
and i really missed this last year so
i'm very happy we can do this again
um yeah so also like i said the code is
there go to my our github get the code
so you can deploy the services all the
infrastructures coaches there all the
codes that you that we just showed you
today is there so you can use this
yourself
so i hope you enjoyed the session um if
you did please leave a green card
if you did not like the session for
whatever reason let us know as well so
we can improve on this because like like
i said we can always be better we can
always improve so let us know
and yeah enjoy the rest of the
conference and we still have some time
for questions so if there are any
questions let us know
and otherwise we can do them afterwards
as well
yep okay so
azure cosmos change the feed does that
have its own event source because let's
say i want to create a new projection of
an existing event source can i then
replay that change speed for that
government relationship yes so the
question can i replay the event uh the
uh change feed uh when i add a new
projection or anything like that so is
it like also events to a sourcing
pattern and elena can yeah
yeah so
basically
that's why we
we were implementing event sourcing with
cosmos db because it was
quite interesting case the change fit is
already even sourcing on its own so
every time you add data it doesn't
matter if you implement event sourcing
and you just append the documents or you
decided that you will update your
documents every time the change fit its
event sourcing and it's always stored
the whole history so even if you created
that projection and you were updating
them over and over again the change fit
will store all the events so for even
for your projection so you can easily
replay
with the original data or with those
projections anytime you want so
okay
yep there's there's like five levels of
consistency i was with cosmos db and
uh basically it depends on your use case
but there is like from the strong
consistency to eventual uh with the
session and two in between
but yeah five different levels and um it
all depends on the use case if you
really need like super super consistent
data then strong consistency and they
have a quorum basically for replicas
they're gonna replicate uh one one of
the replicas will replicate to a
different region and yeah you we will
have no problems with this
so question over here
do you have any idea of the relative
cost difference for an enterprise
solution that's running a classic setup
versus a solution that's run using event
sourcing using the service yep
yeah so the question is uh what is about
to do of course difference like if we
are using this like with old style with
sql and things like that versus if you
are using like these kind of services
with event sourcing and customers to be
um like i'm an architect so it always
depends
but yeah so definitely what you have to
look into when you start actually
modeling your
solution have a look into those costs
and question b actually has a very nice
cost calculator
where you can get like you can create a
message like okay this is about how my
message looks like and this is how many
times per day i expect this to have to
answer this how many times to read this
and you will for custom cosmodb will get
like a nice ovok this is how much we uh
expect you to spend about
um so of course uh materialized views
that elena showed you today is one of
the ways you can actually get that cost
down because instead of every time
reading that whole collection you're
just getting okay this is actually the
view i want this is the information i
want and so this is one of those ways
that you can get the cost down
so there's not like a single answer i
can give you like okay customers b is
more expensive or less expensive than
sql because really depends on how do you
model a solution
i do think it's very important that when
you start looking at this and maybe if
you come from a background where you're
using sql
actually do go in like have
do read about the different services
understand how they work and then
actually build the optimal solution with
this because if you just go okay i'm
going for sql i will just now make this
into documents store it in our customers
b and then just using my same queries
and stuff like that it will definitely
be more expensive so that's why it's so
important to actually understand how
these services work
um and how we can actually implement
those best
solutions the best way
cool
so i know a couple over
a question about the here
under cosmos db so you have sql
cassandra i think right yeah that's apis
basically you can use so so if you have
an on-premise cassandra datastore today
could you then
easily
the idea is that you should be able to
do this
uh yeah of course there there is um
they have they provide those five
different apis and they they say that
you should be able to easily exactly for
this purpose if you have on-premise then
you can easily migrate to cloud and this
should that's how it should work but of
course i heard that there was a couple
of situations when you actually start
doing this there might be some
complications but nothing that cannot be
solved so yes that's that's how it
should work and that's how but don't
expect that it will be like yeah
so also one addition on that uh do have
a look at documentation of microsoft
because they actually explain like what
are the uh
how far they are compatible with which
versions of the apis and what are like
the issues you might run into
but if it's the case and you really want
to migrate from on-premise to cloud and
with the cosmos db and so on they also
support
they will provide the support they will
provide a like kind of consultation like
do you really need to do this maybe not
change your mind but i'm pretty sure
that it should be quite easy
um there will be a delay uh because
basically to generate the projection
uh you have so you have one asia
function this variety data and then
change feed re like which is reacting
and this and you have another another
asian function which is uh generating
projection and again writing in in
cosmos db and then you will have
probably another asia function which
will basically react on those
projections and will populate it to to
the clients for example you can also
have
azure function with
like signalr for example uh but it's
still like three layers basically and of
course they will be delayed they might
be delay for warm up of the function if
it's just started like you know a
morning like some order started to
income and then there's gonna be a delay
but
uh it depends of course on a like i
guess pricing tier like the what's the
plan
might be significant might be not it all
depends on how how you want to actually
implement it but it's definitely
milliseconds might be yeah so indeed if
you have something that's like very like
should be very low latency uh customv
itself provides i think like 99
percentile will be under 10 milliseconds
for functions you would probably want to
go to the premium plan because then you
actually get like the preformed
functions
so you don't have that warm up the delay
of about like a second or something like
whatever it is these days
but yeah so if you really look into that
like do have a look at like more premium
tiers because they actually have some
solutions for this
and in that case i would expect also it
would make sense first in the back
is that you actually can get that locked
by updating but if you aggregate the
views
and store these aggregated views
don't you have to say um so yeah you can
once again this is really about how you
also uh because we just showed you today
okay how do we actually do in fact
sourcing there are some other things
that you need to do for this for example
event storming we're actually looking at
the into this kind of things like okay
where can our events come from uh
can they be like uh simultaneous and
things like that
so you can still
walk into this but if you think about
this beforehand it's easier to solve
this than with grudge there is also
another thing is uh for example when you
do aggregate the events for the
projections the first thing is that uh
you can have a batch of events you can
receive like bulk basically of the
events and it's already like when you
need to to do an update of thousand
times or you received a thousand events
and you do update once so that's one
thing which can make it really really
less possible
and if there is a problem and if there
is a really happening that there is a
i never met that kind of situation but
it could be there is a conflict
resolution in cosmos db they can have
you can either uh provide the specific
rules how to pro how to solve that kind
of issues or you can manually solve them
so but it's like
really you have to create this case
um
yep
uh what kind of api do you actually use
in your samples
default one yeah
the default one so you have cosmos db
and you have different apis the mongodb
cassandra table and sql
and gremlin okay
yes yes yes yes yes but basically um i
mean sql api but it's document store
schema-less so you can operate you can
um it's basically to make it more
comfortable for people from the like
sql world uh you can provide sql queries
you can write it but it's not
recommended twice a recommended way is
basically like cqrs as as we were doing
we write we wrote the data we wrote the
events and then we separated read and
write operations uh created much less
use those projections and that's how we
read it but not like querying in real
time and stuff stuff like this so it's a
lost question and if i miss you i try to
look around but if i didn't issue just
come up the stage or we can talk outside
so
if you need a really high consistency
it would be better
it could be could be i mean what's the
use case
of course it's if you it's yeah the
couple of question times i had this
question like when would you use the
cosmos db um of course i would not be
like every time
let's use cosmos just because uh there
is a use case when you really don't need
because it will be overheard for example
but if i do have the the kind of use
cases that i have my data high volume
data hybrid operation and i need to
represent my data for read operations in
many different projections many
different views for me cosmos would be a
logical like
good way to go but actually it's not
just because of
cosmos db it's more like event sourcing
and secures
but
if you don't really need that kind of
functionality it might be really just be
too too complicated and
normal database is also fine and of
course like once again architects so it
really depends on your scenario um so if
you have like relational data that's
like very relational and like that kind
of data yeah then just put into sql if
you are working like with documents or
like graphs or stuff like that like this
where cosmos db really shines and so as
always it really depends on your
scenario they have they have described
scenarios in documentation if i remember
they were like really have a couple of
the couple of scenarios when they say
okay this is really would be good fit
the rest you can think for yourself so
i would say
it will be nice to check it there on
documentation
so with that uh let's close session like
i said if you have any questions just
come up to us we can talk here we can
talk outside wherever
i hope you enjoyed sessions session i
hope you enjoyed the rest of the
sessions enjoy the conference elena
thank you and thank you for everyone for
being here thank you
[Applause]
you